hello and a very warm welcome to another
edition of talking germany the show
where we do just that to my guest today
is one of Germany's leading novelists
and areas in person auto kirchhof thank
you very very much for joining us today
and I'm going to explain straight up
while you're wearing your glasses yeah
the sunglasses today it's because you've
had a little bit of a problem with your
eyes you agreed to come along for which
we're very very grateful and I tell you
folks it's going to be a good show
bordeaux kirchhof has written a dozen or
so novels and I hasten to add much more
besides he's won many prizes and he's
been at the forefront of German writing
for about three decades his latest work
which will be talking about in detail
has been viewed by many critics as his
very best I for one and I putting my
cards right on the table here I thought
it was magnificent boker tov yeah praise
for your first novel for your latest
novel there how much time when you're
writing a novel like the one you have
for just written yeah how much time do
you spend thinking about people like me
about your readers you mean when I
writing well you're right when I ride
the delk I never saw the Bob the readers
you don't think about no now I am my own
reader and I think how would I feel when
I read this book yeah and and what would
it bother me would I love it would I
have a reason to continue yeah I would
have a reason to 20 decide to put it
beside that and the other one is my wife
yeah I imagine what will my wife sing
about that here and after I've written
let's say two or three copies this book
has seven copies after the shirt copy I
gave it to my wife and she said to me
it's terrible it's not strong enough
it's not her it doesn't hurt it doesn't
hurt it doesn't hurt and did you change
it Radek
well there was one big mistake in the
beginning I wrote it in the first person
you know yeah and and that doesn't work
and I know to ride it in the short
person to be really the storyteller
there's much more work it's more
difficult much more difficult and then I
tried that and then step by step it
works the reason i asked the first
question about their about the reader
sitting at home is you gave us an awful
lot of work to do this time a novel of
nearly 700 pages how tough was it to
write those 700 pages well in the
beginning it wasn't because I had no
plan to make a book of this cease I
never have a master plan when I start
with the book the only thing I knew was
it will be a book dealing with marriage
and dealing with a long relationship
between two people and dealing with love
in in its in the different aspects of
love you know there's a love between men
and an animal a doc it has love between
two people men and women are married
yeah they have to love to to a lover and
two female up and to am a lover their
friendship in this book so these are
these different aspects of love I know
that this will be the most important
point of this book so when I try to do
that to write it it was in the beginning
hundred pager then it became 200 300 and
so it comes from copy to copy the book
was longer in the sixth copy it was 900
pages and then a shorten it I not
shorten it okay that isn't absolutely
thank you for that there are a really
wonderful summary of what Buddha
Kirchhoff's latest novel is all about
you've had your first impressions from
the man and the writer here is more
photo kirchhof doesn't write pulp
fiction even if shunt Roman one of his
many books bears a title meaning just
that in fact in 2008 he was awarded the
prestigious Carl took Mya medal eda I
find every award disconcerting at first
so nice but now 64 bhutto kickoff is one
a number of them even if as in this case
they don't bring you money just the
medal and a cask of wine other cards
look Maya medal winners include
singer-songwriter odo Linden bag and
actor Mario odd off the medal is awarded
for services to the German language he's
a big unknown I can relate to the idea
of awarding a prize for services to the
language because that's what I care
about is well photo cash off has lived
and worked in the frankfurt district of
zacks nowison and by Lake Garda in Italy
for more than 30 years the father of two
now grown-up children he withdraws to
his high-rise apartment to write this is
very develops his subjects and stories
just kinda there's no other art form in
which you can experience so much about
someone else's psyche than in the novel
but the novelist has to appreciate the
value of that and communicated to the
reader thurman ave bomb sometimes he
deals with another person's pain as in
arrows and ashes written in 2007 in this
deeply autobiographical friendship novel
as he calls it kirchhof deals with the
death from cancer of a close friend it's
perhaps his most personal book in his
search for words for the unsayable
the stuff isn't the subject is a late
friend and myself but I'm still alive
it's about the survivor and the dead
that's the subject and you have to find
a language worthy of it at the beginning
of his career kirchhof was sometimes
accused of being superficial and overly
self centered perhaps that was because
of photographs like these taken on one
of his numerous trips as a war
correspondent in the 1980s after a
year-long stay in the Philippines he
published the novel that brought him his
breakthrough in Germany and is so far
sold the most copies in phantom became a
best-seller and has been translated into
13 languages the story of a love affair
between a German photographers model and
his housemaid the exotic setting was a
puppet state that Boras strong
resemblance to the Philippines under the
regime of frettin and Makos rarely has a
German author written so atmospherically
reviewers were as enthusiastic as
readers I feel successful when I can
live for my writing nothing else
interests me most of his books such as
his critically acclaimed parlando from
2001 are too preoccupied with language
to be mass market bestsellers in culebra
and I belong to a generation that
learned to exert power through language
especially through irony Yahoo knee
farlam know what you write but feel it
too otherwise there is no truth in it
that's Kirchhoff's credo even so he
still makes excursions into television
he's written TV scripts and even
presented his own literary chat show
though it was soon canceled because of
low ratings he dealt with his
frustration by writing shunt Roman a
satire about the media good novel says
borokii off of repositories of language
vital and alive and today he's our guest
on talking Germany boroka schaaf
Bordeaux kirchhof let's say it very
interesting in that report we've seen
various different phases of your life in
your career I'd like to talk for a
moment about how you became the person
that you are and to do so I've got a
quote that I thought was extremely
interesting you said my parents fate was
war hours talking about your generation
is burn ality what did you mean well I'm
I'm grown up in a peaceful country
relatively peaceful and I grow up with
the beginning of thick t we have TB time
the medians and I traveled a lot of I
make very some dangerous trips to war
places in two countries with very poor
people and every time I came back I saw
we are live in a area we have a German
expression for that the injured as
ailing the island of people who are
happy in an untroubled way yes right
maybe in a banal way that's what you're
saying and so people in our country
often make they they make themselves the
old
problems you know the problems are what
the most of the people they have food
they have they have a home they have one
car to car they have all right my
children yeah they have all these
electronic stuff so the the biggest
problem is maybe how can I get a good
practicum what it's going on with
facebook I think what it will be the
next better smartphone than I ever have
I wonder if your children would be happy
to hear you saying this let's talk about
them any of you say there's piniella tea
yeah enjoyable yeah the banality is that
you you'll need I'm not forced to to to
do you know I'm very free i can do i can
say what i want i can write whatever I
want I can travel I can there's no no
buddy who says to me I have to do you
have to do this you have to think like
that you have to write this way and so
this is a for me is I can kind of tell
that it's there's there's no this is
it's always a rubber wall you you're you
you're bouncing again yeah fancy against
yeah bouncing of it yeah do you know
what I think you're talking about i
think you're talking about how difficult
it is for people to have real feelings
in some ways let me just see what while
we willis thing to that relationship
Danny I i met i had i made a big
experience when I was very young I
worked in the interstates of an
ice-cream seller and I saw the ice cream
two kids you know so I sold in a in a
Jewish quarter the kids came to me and
said to me how many Jewish people did
your father kill
and we have the one and and and I
thought I get an impression where I'm
from but that was not my situation that
was the situation in the mind of these
kids you know and maybe that the reason
is that in the states that the problems
are much more virulent than here they
have this race problems they have still
the provenance with Jewish people there
now they have the problems with with
Islamic people we in Germany have today
we have we have problems with
anti-semitism we have lumps we have
ozlem can be messy and so on and so call
most of these problems are only in
special areas you know if you can live
in Germany in in an area like me I'll if
you are not connected with these
problems ok boy dragon only in the
media's only I know them I know many
people I know what the problems is but
if I say I closed my door I won't hear
anything about that I can do that let's
talk about your book yeah your big book
the 700 page book you said to me while
we were watching the last report you
said you want me to quote the first
sentence to ya and you can tell me why
that's so very important yes to what you
were doing yeah the first sentence reads
and I'm translating ad hoc yeah yearning
for love is the only serious illness
with which one can grow old even with
another person why is that so important
well after I've written to us recopy of
the book I once lay in my bed at night
I'm couldn't sleep and I asked myself
what really is the point of that book of
all these hundred and hundred pages but
what what's really important and then I
came through this sentence to say how
you how your dick expert returning your
yearning for love yearning for love
you know if you if you think about
laughs you will see that you either have
your a yearning for love or you have
memories but what is laughs in the
present that's what's your fascination
what is love in the present I sing it's
in the present it is a kind of falling
in love or sex maybe but I don't I
really don't know what it means I see
that does not sing it laughs maybe you
you do know what it means because it's
separate you know what it is because
I've got a quote from you your quotas
it's a fascinating sentence that you
wrote you wrote the high point of love
is its durability I just wanted to say
that God just really do there you can
separate love from time yeah you can't
separate love from time though the high
point is as you said it a durability
that's your ability can we just need to
speak about one more aspect because it
is a novel about men and women and about
how they interrelate and you said in an
interview about the book you said I got
to get this absolutely right you said I
owe something to women I owe something
to women why do you owe something to
women well I know women much better than
I know men you know I had intimacy with
women and not as a man and the other
thing is in in the last 40 or 45 years
them only women came to me and and said
you have to change yourself you can't do
that you can't think like that you can
treat me like that and I had I must
think about myself did you listen when
they say did you I listen I listen that
doesn't that does not mean that I that I
did what they want but you listen to do
but I listened roster I always listed
and then the next said the same words
and then
I came to the to the point to say to
myself not only one girlfriend or woman
says is not only 23 say say the same
thing so maybe they are right yeah and I
began to do something good yeah good and
you wrote a good book about it yeah and
went with a friend I never had I never
conversations like that oh dear oh dear
what does this tell us about men we're
gonna have to leave it we might come
back to we might come back okay yeah
let's move on a little bit writing books
is one thing selling books is another
book shops can be wonderful places but
they are of course businesses to
businesses that are these days under
immense pressure a small book shop in
wiesbaden a hidden treasure trove few
passers-by drop in here but those who do
are usually not disappointed s
inscription this but no no there are
only two good bookshops left in the
spotlight and small ones that can also
advise you of course in the big ones I
wouldn't be surprised if I asked for
something by good and the sales
assistant said who's that qui font
software tester good advice and
excellent books that's been paid alloys
winning formula for the past 40 years
despite competition from the internet
and large bookstores in tzfat
Hollister's our advantage is that we
present ourselves differently and that
includes the way we look to outsiders
the face of my book shows east by Naboo
Hangul it's very different in the
mass-market bookstores here the usual
bestsellers dominate arata scism with a
touch of the literary or Harry Potter
like fantasy novels a safe bet you might
think but internet book sales and ebooks
are hitting the big book stores hardest
so they're expanding their range of
products the Kunda finna die English
Alice
our customers can find anything they
could wish for such as extra gift items
or treats for themselves passing some
customers for instance we sell utensils
to go with cookbooks or scented candles
to suit a specific health book punch
printable for cats that's not going to
appeal to literary purists and precisely
that fact may be a blessing for small
book sellers because people who just
want good books often feel much better
served by their shops because if let's
try some quick answers this time round
here we're going to talk about books and
book shops do you have a favorite book
shop in front foot yes it's a and how
you say Antiqua antique oh yeah it's a
place that sells antique book yes and
it's an old friend of me and I came to
this place two times a year and I I saw
the ball with the books and I picked one
two three four five six seven and maybe
20 30 books and then I pay 50 euro and
you taken away absolutely happy
beautiful books good I love book shops
there they can be very comforting places
I don't let I don't need new books in
the only new books no okay um are you as
a writer affected by the changes that
are going on in the book trade yes I am
how really well they are less readers
and 20 or 30 years before yeah half
maybe half never the half and I think we
these elect the electronic boom the big
electronic boom in every respect is
really it's it's it's the opposite of
reading a book you know playing with if
you have you ever owned with your phone
with the opposite of reading a book oh
yeah have you ever read an e-book no no
I have seen that I have seen that at the
beach a couple of years weeks before and
somebody told me now I have forty-five
percent left and I didn't understand
that so that was for me the end of the
war he books here dear reader books on
the internet
me do you order books on the internal
yes yes I did oh you're a sinner okay
yeah I try to avoid it no I by our board
books by amazon that's Jared hear it
here yeah why do you write novels well I
think the novel if the only way to learn
about something this strange or the
other in the other people in another one
there's something really strange and
other you know the other neither one of
these other yeah and to understand it
and to tell about this the only way to
to bring that to other people is by a
novel because you you have you have you
know you have can have enough space you
have enough time it takes time it's not
enough to do that in 90 minutes it's not
you cannot do that in a picture you
cannot do that in a small movie you
cannot do that in poems I seeing you
need a big novel for that I often say
that from from my point of view as a
reader a novel is a privileged form of
communication because it really gives
you it gives you a deeper conversation
and understanding there's a privilege
form of comm commerce occasion at a
comic conversation and it is a a slowly
slowly form yeah it's very slowly and
you right let's say four or five years
and then after a half a year or one year
you became the first antha back yeah the
feedback okay one more question on the
novels yeah can you teach people to
write novels know enough novels but you
can teach people to to tell something to
do to be a storyteller to tell a small
small
you know a slice yeah a slice you know
maybe some you come to you come to split
place and you meet an old friend yeah
you haven't seen in 40 years what
happened to tell really to tell about
this yeah really to find words for this
and not to bring that in cliches then
that you can learn I think so yeah so
we're looking for something not general
but something very specific and will
answer end to to to bring your own
suffering in in a language yeah this is
very important to bring yourself in a
language but don't not not to open to
open everything you know you need not
open your heart but you can bring the
pain of your heart in a book but you
need to open your heart something very
different for some time now the Catholic
Church here in Germany and elsewhere of
course has been mired in allegations
concerning sexual abuse of children by
its clergy the German Bishops Conference
ordered an external investigation but
that probe is now being called off it's
a decision that has been fiercely
criticized by many of the victims actor
Magilla Bronte's was sexually abused as
a child by a priest at his school he
thinks it's scandalous that the roman
catholic church in Germany has
terminated its inquiry into alleged
abuse in its institutions as long as
nothing's out in the open they have no
credibility the abuse allegations have
shaken Germany many cases were in
Catholic institutions where children and
teenagers were thought to be in
especially safe hands lawyer Thomas
Vista was a special prosecutor and has
access to the files he thinks the
Catholic Church's argument that it wants
to protect those wrongly suspected is a
smoke screen notice an HDL of course a
proper investigation always involves
victims priests or other clergy who have
done nothing wrong
have nothing to fear so I consider the
protection argument hypocritical on this
argument at a few azhaga foo muniya
sagging Vega horseshit Canisius College
in Berlin was one of the schools
especially hard hit by reports of abuse
in the 1970s it was the scene of
repeated cases of sexual molestation
headmaster Klaus mattis played a major
role in initiating the inquiry in 2010
the ALF clear form is the investigation
of sex abuse has to be conducted by
independent outside agencies that's the
fundamental experience of all the
institutions involved in the cases of
abuse oh but no investigation can take
place if there's no internal willingness
to give others access to information
shaft Gibbs ich danke 9 blinken
cillessen Indiana cotton three years ago
at all Abby and Bavaria was also in the
line of fire since then steps have been
taken to prevent sexual abuse in the
future and victims have been given
compensation it remains to be seen
whether the German Bishops Conference
will attempt to launch a fresh inquiry
but there's dissatisfaction at the
grassroots level Hina Maria she slub a
Catholic priest notices it every day
yeah he had a ton of decorations from
people leaving the church is growing
again on my desk because there's a lack
of trust because preconceptions were
confirmed because people say they always
suspected as much and that it's
perfectly obvious that we didn't want to
clear things up yeah garnish now Framing
this failure has led to mistrust and
resignation among the victims this is LA
we see acoustic dust I think it's very
important for the victims not to keep
quiet not to another Church to go back
to business as usual after these
dreadful crimes physical abuse of
innocent children and sexual abuse
victims like me gala Bronte's certainly
believe that cases of abuse must
continue to be investigated boroka
Shalford a couple of years ago you wrote
an essay in a leading german news
magazine in Spiegel magazine the first
sentence was I have been abused why did
you do that well I did that at the
highest point of this discussion and the
discussion before was for me too
abstract to more much more to theory
very abstract and I wanted to fill that
was really experience to try to to find
language a language for that and that's
why I did that and I found some from my
opinion very simple true sentences for
this what happened to me let me just
interrupt for a second because it's very
interesting what you're saying because
they I've quoted the first sentence
which was I've been abused the second
sentence was the following it's a word
that is not much use yeah what do you
mean with that I didn't understand this
really good yeah you said that the
second quest the second sentence in the
essay that you wrote was it is a word
miss parole yah yah yah yah it is not
much use yeah that's right yeah
why did you say that well it is it it is
a its itself it's it's a part of of the
theory you know it it doesn't tell
something everybody who hear her set or
read it reads it sink or fields I know
what it means but this is very
subjective yeah and to feel that it's
quite another thing i think the what the
word miss Rowe is maybe this pro abuse
abuse is may be good for lawyers yeah
let's say offer for journalists but for
writer than me this this bird club
doesn't open a door but it closed the
door and I like to open it and when they
open the door or the window you will see
that behind the door are quite other
things in your novel I've got another
line from your novel that when i was
reading it it lept aunt at me yeah it
had a big impact on me and the line was
use bro yeah and abuse miss bro yeah you
said in the novel are very close
together that's right that's right price
me because i thought was classroom but i
didn't know what you meant yeah if you
say this is Miss brow abuse yep then you
have the question what the use you know
in the states in the different different
states of tell Thea of America there are
different laws what is the right use of
sexuality what is what what is legal and
what is illegal I've got you yeah
terrible I mean
inside inside inside a marriage you know
how you how you have it what it what is
the right way to sleep with you with
your wife you know and I think you have
to think about the use and the abuse you
know and then any we see that the border
is fluently that was the point here
Omega the border is fluently and the
other thing is my own experiences that
the abuse was combined with expects of
love and and and another experience
another be they shall experience for me
is at being being a man a human being
you have the risk that other people will
fall in love with you or will like you
or will have a desire to you you know
that's it it's an existential risk you
have and if a woman is beautiful it's
beautiful to her and she may be happy
but there is a risk inside that the risk
that men saw them saw them walking say
yes at the end you can you you can't cut
you you can't separate this risk from
from the fact that you are a beauty or a
human being which is what happened when
you were a boy you were an attractive
young boy yeah let me let me just what
happened to you when you were a boy did
it make you a writer it was one of the
one of the reasons I became a writer was
to to try to find a language for
sexuality I made a very odd
a early experience of sexuality combined
with a sick kind of love let's say and I
have no words no language for that it
was for me a kind of miracle I don't
know what it was you know what it is and
then a couple of years later I know that
but it was too late there was still
something the feeling of missing in me
and so I need to find a language to
compensate this yeah to to be able wants
to be able to to tell or a tool to write
about these early experiences not in a
theoretic way thank you yeah thank you
for that thank you for sharing some very
personal thoughts about a very person
their area of your life yeah that's
right well we've mentioned already that
border kirchhof lives in the german city
of frankfurt it's Germany's only city
that can claim to have anything like a
manhattan-style skyline and fittingly it
is Germany's banking and financial
capital but what else does it have to
offer let's have a look landing at
Franklin International Airport one of
the three most important airline hubs in
Europe Frankfurt is also home to Germany
seven tallest skyscrapers
popular science Lankford is a tiny town
in global terms with 700,000 residents
you can't really impress the world but
the high-rises make it feel bigger I was
in China reason to see who has oval disk
or is it there are more than 40 in the
city centre at 259 meters the commands
Bank Tower is the tallest Frankfurt also
has one of the world's major stock
exchanges many of the skyscrapers are
bank headquarters
amid the towers is the old opera house
Frankfurt is nothing if not a city of
contrasts just a few minutes walk from
the main railway station is Frank Fritz
best-known shopping street sian
nearby is a monument to the city's most
famous son and poet johann wolfgang von
goethe when the sun is out the banks of
the river mine are a popular place for a
stroll
numerous museums line the riverbanks
there's been a bridge at this font since
the 13th century it leads to the old
town several of the historic buildings
here were carefully restored or rebuilt
after the Second World War they include
the Town Hall which is over 600 years
old locals like to gather at this
covered market the climate ala here you
can find local specialties as well as
fine foods from around the world in no
other German city do so many people of
so many different nationalities live so
close together the region is also
renowned for producing apple wine which
is served in many pubs and restaurants
in Frankfurt here the high-rise banking
metropolis is very down-to-earth indeed
auto cash office frankfurt a lovable or
an unlovable place it has become a
lovable place that's good this has
become when i first came to frankfurt
1970 i guess i came i went there because
there was of the famous literary
publishing house to come in frankfurt
now through campus in berlin and i'm
still in frankfurt and at this time
frankfurt was only in a bathtub are
still with a building site a building
site there now nothing like nothing than
this and most of these of the skyscraper
they were built in the 70s and the 80s
and when when this was finished and when
the when the underground railway was
finished and then became frankfurt more
and more normal city and i have
beautiful friend there i have a very
nice apartment looking over the whole
city it's a great view yeah and i have
the mind river 100 meter apart and so I
I really love it to be there end
important thing is my children they are
grown up in Frankfurt and for them it's
a natural home you know they have this
natural feeling I'm at home here I can
imagine exactly what you're saying cuz
my so so the feeling of my kids are my
old feeling has been cut my own feeling
that's the same that has happened with
me because I have kids who were born in
berlin turn up in berlin and the oberlin
you know it's is to come my home in that
way as well to what next time I go to
Frankfurt what is the what is your
favorite place in the city oh why should
I go favorite well it's nice you know if
you've ever warm evening to eat at the
Opera place it's nice and sometimes this
this street where I'm live nearby
schweitzer Sir Arthur's out there are
some beautiful restaurant sitting in
outside in summer time
in winter time I don't know and winter
time you have to go it's a windy city's
yeah I want you sell your witness it
between the the big houses are always
winter and but it's it's nice to walk at
the mind river and in the in the summer
evening they are sitting there are
hundreds and hundreds people's just
looking to the river looking to the
houses when I came to Frankfurt nobody
would sit at this is there nobody there
are some roses and there there's the
grass and some banks and some old people
went walking there with a doc's you know
and today are hundreds and hundreds
young people are sitting there drinking
beer and hearing music and playing with
your phones with her phones and looking
reading reading novels on kindle so they
don't read and say to each other
scientific know sometimes I go
especially go to this place with Mike
with my bike to see if every bar if any
any of these many people is reading a
novel but maybe some two or three and
then I went home and say forget it and
go go go go on write it ok keep on
writing go to cash off please please
keep on writing I enjoyed your last book
so much I'm looking forward to next when
he's told me already is writing another
Bob will have to wait to see what it's
all about that's your lot with the Frank
thoughtful and eloquent auto kirchhof
I'm very grateful he's been here today
there's more in my blog on the talking
Germany website where our shows are also
archived you've enjoyed today's show as
much as I have and do come back next
week until then bye bye and truth thank
you thank you
you